office minister james cleverley joining
us now mr cleverly good morning to you
uh let's just start with um the nato
base that we heard about over um the
last couple of days uh reports in this
morning's newspapers
that up to uh three
former
military personnel have died in that
explosion do we know anything more about
that
well i don't have details on the
individuals that have been
injured and hurt or whether on their
british nationals obviously if there are
british nationals involved the
uk foreign office will
be there to support
we do remind people that the travel
advice is that they shouldn't be going
to ukraine we completely understand
the urge to help and be supportive but
obviously
we we we are telling people it is not
safe to travel to ukraine but obviously
if british nationals have been hurt or
killed the the government is there to
support but the government can't confirm
this morning whether or not british
nationals have perished
no indeed i can't i can't uh i i can't
speak about
those details i don't have
that detail at the moment but as i say
the uk government is there to support
people if they do need our help but we
do urge people whether they're
tempted to help militarily or whether
they are trying to
be
supportive in a humanitarian sense are
our advice is that people should not be
going to ukraine
that there are other
ways that they can help and we we advise
them to donate to a recognized charity
rather than putting themselves at risk
okay explosions in kiev again overnight
it looks as though another residential
building has been hit it looks as though
the russians are getting quite desperate
hitting buildings like this just to
clarify we do it every day that's a war
crime is it
yes so the targeting of civilians or
civilian infrastructure is is a war
crime uh the the the situation in
ukraine is is terrible and it's obvious
that the the russian military are not
achieving
the goals that they set themselves
they're not achieving the goals that
vladimir putin has a set for them the
defense by the ukrainians is
is is is amazing and we continue
to support whether it be through
humanitarian support economic support
and those defensive military equipments
that we have
provided the ukrainian armed forces
to that end an aid to a close aid to
president putin victor
zolotov says that progress is slower
than expected surprising that someone
close to putin would actually
acknowledge that we also believe that
russia is asking for chinese aid that
has been denied by china what's
britain's advice to china we've heard
what the united states has said they've
warned china against getting involved
well what we're saying to
all countries is that they should
denounce this unprovoked illegal attack
into into ukraine by russia they should
not in any way be supporting russia and
we urge countries to join the uk and the
international community in condemning
and sanctioning russia to choke off the
finances which are funding putin's war
effort there is no justification at all
for this attack and we urge uh china and
all countries around the world to
denounce it and absolutely not to
support it of course you're a foreign
office minister we told china that have
we told them to butt out of this war
well we have made it clear to
all countries around the world
that that they should condemn this
action we saw at the united nations an
unprecedented scale in that vote at the
general assembly against the actions
that russia have taken we are seeing
every day more countries joining the uh
joining the the countries that are
sanctioning uh russian uh individuals
vladimir putin and the people around him
and what we do is we're urging everybody
to make it very very clear that they
oppose this invasion that they will take
action that they will sanction
putin and those people around him and
they will prevent him from pursuing this
as i say this completely unjustified war
against ukraine and has china done that
have they given us that guarantee
well uh
i mean china's statements are in the uh
in the public domain uh we feel that
that countries should be really
unequivocal in their uh opposition to
what's going on they should condemn a
lot of countries
did so at the united nations we would
like everybody to continue pushing
russia
as you said in your introduction we're
introducing now
or rather just last night legislation
was passed which enables us to apply
even more sanctions on top of the ones
that we've already applied and what we
want to do is is have the international
community speak with one voice
condemning this attack putting real
financial pressure on to vladimir putin
so that he can no longer pursue this uh
war of aggression against and i do want
to talk to you about oligarchs in a
second but i just want to clarify uh
copper bottom it has china guaranteed to
the uk that they will not get involved
in the war in ukraine
well we haven't had that statement from
china um but what we are looking to do
is ensure that china and indeed every
other country around the world is
condemning russia's actions absolutely
not supporting russia in its uh
aggression against ukraine and indeed
sanctioning russia and putting real
financial pressure on russia that's what
we're calling on the international
community to do that's what we will
continue to push for
uh until this war comes to a conclusion
the russian forces leave ukraine it's a
briefing that the ministry of defense
puts out every morning about this time
and intelligence update as they call it
i just want to share it with our viewers
and i'm
interested to hear your view on this and
and particularly um the second point
about reports um suggesting that russia
may seek to stage a referendum in
kirsten an attempt to legitimize the
area as a breakaway
uh republic similar to donetsk what's
your interpretation
of what that means
well it's quite clear that
vladimir putin's original intention was
to have a kind of a lightning war a very
fast war to capture ukraine take heave
uh and instill uh install rather a
puppet government that is clearly not
working they are failing in those
military aims so it's now quite obvious
that they are that that vladimir putin
and the russian military are attempting
some form of legitimacy or justification
for their military actions the uk is
completely clear
ukraine is a
sovereign territory they have a right to
protect their own borders they
you know
a fake a faux election to try and
justify russia's aggression to ukraine
will be recognized for exactly what it
is and that is a fake and what we are
calling upon russia to do what we're
calling on putin to do is to end this
war and end it immediately
okay
fat founding mission continuing there's
so much to talk to you about this
morning i'll crack on an article in the
telegraph this morning from the prime
minister
in which he talks about solar he talks
about wind he talks about nuclear he
talks about
north sea oil doesn't mention fracking
are we giving up on fracking
well we have uh made it absolutely clear
that
we need to move away from our collective
addiction to hydrocarbon energy the uk
has really led the way we saw this at
cop 26 in glasgow till end of last year
the uk has really led the way
in pushing for alternative energy
production moving away from gas moving
away from oil the
the situation in ukraine presents a
unique
uh and terrible uh additional emphasis
to us collectively to move away from our
addiction on uh
hydrocarbons and it's absolutely right
we we we seek to do that
because it's the right thing to do for
the environment and as we're now seeing
it denies russia an incredibly important
source of income that they rely upon to
fund this war
an answer to my question
well as i say we have made it absolutely
clear that we are looking ultimately to
move away from our hydrocarbons in the
uk we want long-term economically and
ecologically
sustainable routes
specific decisions on
you know specific means of energy
generation
is for the energy secretary but
ultimately our direction of travel is to
move away from hydrocarbons because as i
say it's the right thing to do for the
environment it's the right thing to do
economically and in this particular
situation with ukraine it's the right
thing to do to deny russia a means of
funding its war effort we've got one of
the heads of the fracking companies on a
little bit later on quadrilla they're
looking at sealing their wells as early
as today should they do it or should
they wait
well as i say okay the the uh individual
decisions
is a matter for uh the uh the energy uh
department but the point that i've made
is that our direction of travel in the
uk
is to move towards an economically
ecologically and
and and and as we're saying with regard
to russia uh uh a more diplomatically
sustainable model of energy generation
and that is ultimately him would you
steal the site today or not could you
seal that well today or not if you were
the head of quadriller
to be honest with you i'm dealing i'm
dealing more i'm focusing more we're
trying to bring uh the uh the conflict
in ukraine to uh
talking about it as the lead story in
the telegraph today i get the importance
i get the importance i get the
importance of uh securing
energy in the in the short term that is
an incredibly important point and the
prime minister will be speaking to the
international community to to do that
but ultimately as i have said the real
important thing for us to focus on is
ultimately moving away from our
addiction to hydrocarbons because that's
a quick thought saudi arabia before i
let you go and ecologically the right
thing to do just a quick thought on
saudi before i let you go here's uh
prime minister heading to saudi arabia
later on today they um killed 81 men
over the weekend we're always told that
we bring up human rights with them every
time we talk to them it's not getting us
very far is it
well
i
used to be the minister for middle east
north africa
the uk has a long standing and
principled opposition to the use of the
death penalty that is a conversation
that i have had
with saudi arabia when i was in this
role i know my uh
my
my colleague amanda milley who's taken
over that role she will have had
conversations along those lines our
position is absolutely clear we think it
is wrong
as a uh as a as a
as a response to uh criminal behavior
that is our long-standing principal
position we will have communicated that
to saudi arabia i have no doubt we will
do in response to the executions that
have been recently announced okay but
we'll still do business with them but
sadly we are out of time so we'll have
to pick that up again next time we chat
mr cleverley thank you very much indeed
for joining us thank you